Robert Downey jr. Ziya man went through
a profound journey in Avengers endgame
and delivered an unforgettable line that
was a touching call back to the very
beginning of the Marvel movie franchise
as it turns out the iconic moment almost
never happened because Downey jr.
reportedly didn't want to say Tony
Stark's last major line even though co
directors join Anthony Russo lifted the
ban on spoilers for Avengers ends game
we're offering you one last warning
major spoilers ahead and now for the
juicy details during a recent appearance
on cinema plans for your planned podcast
the Russo brothers opened up about
Tony's final scene in Avengers endgame
as you might recall the hero equipped
his own suit with the Infinity stones
snapped his fingers and promptly turned
Thanos and his minions into space dust
white before Tony mirrored Thanos his
decimation from an affinity wore the mad
Titan was clearly convinced he had the
upper hand
proudly proclaiming I'm inevitable but
in a move displaying all the dry cool
wit that makes Tony who he is he flashed
his hand to show that OSI had the
Infinity stones and then he said it I am
Iron Man of course the line is a
callback to the end of 2008 Iron Man I
am Iron Man
sadly the snap takes a toll on tony's
body and he dies shortly after that he
manages to speak a few more words before
passing away and then we get to hear him
one more time in a heartwarming message
that he recorded prior to his death but
Tony's last big line is his proudest
ershon of his heroism but hold
everything as Joe and Anthony Russo tell
it's Tony originally didn't say those
words at all in fact he originally
didn't say anything in that moment an
early cut of the film simply had Tony
snap his fingers and that was that enter
Avengers end game editor Jeff Ford who
pitched the idea of having Tony say I am
Iron Man
once they heard the concept the Russo
brothers knew they had to reshoot the
seam of that line included but
apparently Downey jr. was initially and
easy with the idea it took some
convincing before he finally agreed to
do a reshoot as Joe Russo revealed
dinner with him like two weeks before
we're supposed to shoot it and he was
like I want to go back and that
emotional state J Russo goes on to
explain that producer Joe Silva is a
close personal pal of Tony Jr's and he
just so happened to be eating with them
according to Joe at silver
enthusiastically blurted out what are
you talkin ever once Downey jr. was on
board the crew reportedly headed back to
the studio to reshoot the scene as we
said before the newly added line servers
are touching nods to the very beginning
of the MCU but the whole reshooting
process turned out to be a callback to
Downey jr. humble beginnings as Iron Man
as Anthony Russo explains the stage that
we shot that shot on was adjacent to the
stage where Robert Downey jr.
screen-tested for Iron Man well if that
doesn't give you chills we don't know
what will Downey jr. might have been
worried about stepping back into
character for the powerful scene but
we're so glad he ultimately came around
the final line he shot is easily one of
the most memorable moments of the entire
film and as many fans can attest
Avengers endgame just wouldn't have been
the same without Tony Stark going out
with a bang
and the biting remark that's sort of his
calling card you know check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more exclusive looper videos about the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single
one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]